so yeah I mean you're in Japan
I wanted to get you on in L.A but then
uh like because we had a bunch of other
things scheduled and it just it didn't
work yeah
absolutely packed we're here because of
you guys yeah oh well I I didn't do
anything well yeah thank you thank you
directed you towards the area yeah he
was mailing but it was using the credit
that's fine
um when did we meet now we met at that
uh party uh yeah in June so and we're
what August now yeah yeah yes so from
the middle of June to the middle of
August like yeah literally it was like
crazy Japan okay and then two months
later we're in Japan oh yeah I mean I I
feel like sometimes you meet YouTubers
you're like oh you're like a normal dude
who just also makes YouTube videos and
you get along really well and I was like
oh yeah you should definitely come again
yeah
a lot of times you sound like to meet
people you're like oh oh my gosh you are
a lot yeah yeah there's a lot of those
yeah I was surprised that you decided to
come to Japan this quickly because
mostly you meet someone who like oh do
you want to come here to this place and
like yeah one day and then like two
years passes and then you get the
message but you guys was just like I
love to just be impulsive with stuff
like this right well it's just it's like
everything lines up it makes sense let's
do it like don't don't and like there's
enough help now he's like I I'm a very
one-track mind and I don't know if
that's if everybody else is like that or
if it's just me but it's like if I have
to start trying to do too many things at
the same time everything falls apart I
get nothing so yeah being able to have
people that help organize stuff just
like okay what do you think about Japan
they're like okay and then they just
start working on it it's like
oh my God it's really really so you came
for the first time in 2019 yeah and you
just loved it yeah this place is amazing
I honestly I think if anybody has any
intention of ever coming to Japan
you have to do it it has to be in your
bucket list you have to come to Japan
make it figure out how to make it work
what's so good about it you tell me yeah
Tokyo is everything every major city
wishes it was
it is like America but Disneyland mixing
the same thing where it's like a city
that I'm familiar enough with yeah
because it's like a lot of everything is
like English or like you know uses our
alphabets yeah you can write it and
decipher it yeah um but it's like clean
and convenient and predictable like it's
it's bizarre because it's like Los
Angeles is a nightmare
and this is great chocolate isn't too
bad yeah right public transport system
as well we have yet to run into any
issues with public transport like we're
not maybe we're just avoiding rush hour
and whatnot but like you show up and oh
oh but even the changes even during rush
hour it somehow works yeah you just have
to deal with the crowd but like it's
just it's just cramped it's just cramps
but everything's still on time somehow
yeah I just like when we normally back
home like I don't drink at all when we
go out because I'm driving yeah you're
just like yeah yeah I drink every day
yeah a beer two beers well that was one
thing
that was one thing as someone who grew
up in England I could never understand
about American culture which is this
culture of having a designated driver
because I'm like damn imagine if you
have to go out and one of you just has
to like commit to not having fun you
know like I couldn't I wouldn't I just
wouldn't go out you know like even if
there's just that one time yeah and it's
like rotating because in Australia it's
not who's the designated driver it's
who's the least drunk here
Australia is a very interesting place
you should come to Australia it's kind
of like white trash America but also at
the same time it's like way more
together hold on pause
what did you say
Australia is like why trash America yeah
I think it's right
but it's nice
I mean I don't I don't mean that
wholeheartedly
but I still stand by it like there's
something a little bit crazier wait have
you been to Australia yeah once
whereabouts were you uh Melbourne oh
okay okay like there's something about
us
I'm gonna add a loophole it could have
also been the people that I was hanging
out yeah it might have been
well I guess like yeah there was a lot
of crazy [ __ ] that happens in Australia
oh absolutely I mean yeah like
Australia's like the Florida of the
world oh absolutely yeah absolutely
that's what I mean yeah yeah no okay
okay I get it in that sense yes
definitely it is what's the difference
between Florida and white trash
[ __ ] you got me there
[Music]
Florida
it didn't drag me faster
there's something in the water in
Florida there's something in the war in
Australia as well yeah this place I like
Japan a lot yeah I like Australia too it
was either we were going to go back to
Australia come to Japan it's it's nice
going to Australia or the UK or America
after being here for too long because
you after a while you kind of get bogged
down by all the rules and all the things
you've been following okay I just want
to go somewhere when there's a problem
that people figure it out not the people
that are freaking out and going um what
do we do what do we do this guy said he
wants some tippers
yeah I mean it's it's it's weird because
I think visiting Japan is I think I
honestly do think Japan is one of the
best countries to visit in the world uh
if you want to live here there's other
things you have to keep in mind it's
still an amazing country to live in but
it's a very different experience
perfect and definitely after you know
being stuck in there for covid I didn't
miss a lot of let's say like the chiller
aspects of other countries yeah yeah
when it comes to just attitude right
yeah I think attitude is a big thing
where sometimes you just want to go to a
place or you know work somewhere where
you don't have to worry about getting
approval or just should I be worried
about doing this very specific thing you
know a very specific thing with little
to no consequences but they make it seem
like there's a whole heap of
consequences I like I like I totally
fine following the rules if they make
sense
a lot of America has stuff that doesn't
make sense too yeah have you ever
learned about like the drug
classifications like the drug scaling no
I think the UK actually follows
similarly to uh marijuana is classified
worse than methamphetamine wait what
what so we're in the UK we have like a b
yeah so marijuana is like I'm gonna
double check that out yeah are you an
expert well I mean we've talked about it
before I mean as you know drug experts
here you know yeah of course you know
yeah but yeah I believe in the UK
marijuana is a Class C drug yeah cocaine
and ecstasy and all those are like cast
class A drugs like I've never heard of
what a Class B drug is so schedule one
speed schedule one is marijuana heroin
LSD ecstasy blah blah blah and then of
course nowhere in these are like
nicotine yeah yeah or anything like that
right and so it's like to me that's one
of those rules where it's like from like
a scientific stand like standpoint like
there's definitely like no science has
been done yeah yeah you want to have
rules government like right exactly
right and so it's like be concise and be
like realistic with the rules don't just
make [ __ ] up yeah
that could apply to a lot of things
though right yeah
like so some things I feel like just
have to do with like the pr or the let's
say the public perception of them yeah I
mean I would argue Japan does that but
in the opposite end when it comes to
things like marijuana do they just think
like oh all drugs are just as bad as
each other so marijuana is just as bad
as heroin and meth and all this
surprisingly lacks in some places though
but I think it's because they haven't
ever had like big disasters or anything
so there's some some rules here like
that's weirdly okay like weirdly okay
with it I um there's a few I I had some
things in mind I forgot but the fact
that you can drink alcohol in a lot of
places that you normally think that
other countries will be like maybe don't
like you openly drink alcohol no problem
right the culture on alcohol here is
really do you drink alcohol alcohol in
public yeah absolutely you drink alcohol
on the train you can drink alcohol on a
busy but I tell you what you can't do in
public okay smoke cigarettes
you can smoke cigarettes inside in a
restaurant or in designated smoking
areas
you can't smoke outside on the streets
where are you supposed to that seems
like the only place you would go
welcome to Japan can you get a domestic
flight you don't need to show an idea at
any point that's cool you just walk on
the plane yeah I get because it's
America that's not how it is America
they stick there they got 911 though so
yeah